since motivation is such a big factor in
language learning success the obvious
answer is which language are you keenest
to learn where where are you most
enthusiastic
and the motivation to learn a language
can be you know anything I've often said
that it's it's a Pity that in Canada
in the school system kids in the English
language school system are forced to
learn French because that is one of the
two official languages of Canada that's
not a very strong motivator
to some extent I believe it doesn't
matter what you study because once you
get going once you start learning
languages and you know how to learn
languages and you've done it once and
you've been successful you can learn as
many languages as you want